[Music]
when you use virtual reality at home
you're always trying not to touch
anything your real-world surroundings
the thinking goes break the illusion of
VR but it turns out that if you merge
the two things you end up with an
experience that's far more immersive at
the Void a quote hyper reality facility
their melding state-of-the-art VR tech
with real-world physicality and in doing
so they're leading a wave of
location-based VR it's a little bit
video game a little bit laser tag and
feels more like an actual adventure than
anything else on the market and we have
fire in the void every VR space has a
real-world counterpart so physical walls
and real-world peripherals intensify
that tactility I thought this was inside
no we're outside it's a starry night
when you step into a virtual world you
step in untethered you step in wearing
equipment that is there not just to get
you to see the environment but to feel
it as well so this is the so called back
top system on the back there is a
computer and a big battery pack on the
front there's a bunch of haptics kind of
rumble packs
and then you put it on and then there's
one more fun part now with the headset
which is also part of the rapture system
a little bit of it is kind of off the
shelf and a lot of it is made special by
the void the the hmd the head-mounted
display is actually an oculus rift and
there's also a leap motion module on the
front of it so it tracks your hands
still seeing my hands is never going to
lose its appeal or novelty hyper-reality
as they call it and then other stuff on
the inside that they have made
themselves but that's really the heart
of the headset but for all this tech
hyper-reality actually uses some
old-school magic theory virtual reality
and its truest sense is a form of magic
magic is just creating a new reality for
people using the tools that are
available whether that's picking up a
coin and using sleight of hand to make
someone think even if it's just for a
second that that coin could Vann
that's a little reality that you were
able to create for VR is the same way
we're trying to create new realities
that people believe in so it makes sense
to use magic principles to take that to
his farthest extent and really get
people embedded and immersed in these
worlds it's easy to assume that the void
would be in a tech or entertainment hot
spot like Seattle or Silicon Valley or
Los Angeles but it's here half hour
outside Salt Lake City while the company
has plans to expand to other cities in
the near future for now they're keeping
it local we've learned a lot this year
about the process getting people into
the void and out of the void the best
way to do that most efficient way to do
that how do we track them as accurately
as possible how do we get them to
interact with objects as accurately as
possible how do we represent where their
eyes are looking and what their emotions
are the people around because there's so
much communication is nonverbal we want
to capture that and that's been one of
the bigger technical challenges we've
had but one that fortunately we don't
have to just solve ourselves because
there's a whole industry out there
trying to also solve this very problem
if I walk over to a wall and I reach out
to touch that wall I'm gonna feel it and
if it's bricks I'm gonna feel bricks if
I if something blows up whoa okay the
door exploded yeah everything just went
off that haptic feedback is really
something I'm going to feel the blast of
that explosion inspire me to feel that
out and once it's more than just your
eyes reality's way more than describes
and so we represent all of those things
in the voice to different degrees and
it's the compilation of these sensory
effects that combined together to create
a new reality and then we just don't
just make a regular reality we make an
impossible reality for you to play
so I have done a lot of things in
virtual reality but I can't say I've
ever done something that brought
together so many different types of
experiences into a single one let alone
one that was so completely unique the
end result combines elements of video
games movies and real-world
obstacle courses but the fact that you
share the experience with other people
makes it more than the sum of its parts
your partners aren't logged in at
computers hundreds of miles away they're
right there with you in the room and
that social aspect sticks with you long
after you come out it's not hard to
imagine that this is going to get VR
into the hands and onto the faces of
many many many many more people than
might have tried it otherwise
[Music]